let's speak now to hey mr bretton gordon
former head of the british army's
chemical weapons unit hamish always good
to have you on the channel um
before we delve into what is what may
well happen in ukraine for those who are
not as of with the rules as you what are
the rules that govern whether or not a
country can use chemical or biological
weapons
well number one you can't chemical and
biological weapons have been
uh illegal really since the start time
of the geneva convention was first
conceived back in the 1920s there are a
number of other conventions like the
chemical weapons convention signed in
1996 by
most countries around the world
including russia that outlaws the use of
chemical weapons
biological weapons is a slightly
different area there is the biological
and toxin weapons convection which
outlaws them but the basic premise these
are absolutely horrendous weapons
indiscriminate mainly affects civilians
of course soldiers tend to have gas
masks and other protections so they are
illegal and horrendous under every law
that one can
conceive
what is their utility then for someone
like vladimir putin of course certainly
plenty of evidence that they have been
deployed
in his name before
what is their utility when it comes to a
combat the types of combat that we are
seeing in ukraine at the moment which is
an awful lot of street to street house
to
house
well i tend to agree with a lot of other
commentators about what's been called
the russian playbook in syria i've seen
the russians are very close quarters
over the last six years
in syria and unfortunately chemical
weapons are what i've learned from my
syrian experience chemical weapons are
morbidly brilliant and you'd use them
all the time if you had no morals or
scruples because
in
syria the towns and cities that were
attacked very similar to what we're
seeing
in ukraine with kiev and other cities
once these cities are raised to the
ground the building's
fallen down it's almost impossible for
attackers to get a foothold and the
russians know all about this from
stalingrad in the second world war over
a million red army soldiers died
defending
stalingrad but what happened in syria is
after the four-year conventional battle
for aleppo in north west syria
in december 2016 on 13 days a sad drop
chlorine barrel bombs and broke that
siege because the chlorine seeps
underground because it's heavier than
air and people hide in the rubble and
underground
and the chlorine either kills them
underground or forces them above ground
to be shot or captured and that also
worked for assad in
a suburb called ghouta and a suburb
called duma in 2017 and 2018. so they
can be very very successful and
unfortunately of course in august 2013
we had a massive sarin attack uh in
damascus and the british government
voted in september 2013 not to punish
hassan and the americans followed suits
and i think that is really underwriting
why we are here now because that failure
to punish assad gave a green light to
every dictator despot rogue state and
terror group to use them and i think
putin thinks he can use them with
impunity yeah difficult to disagree with
that part of your analysis analysis so
what then should we be doing what then
can we do if anything is it just a case
of
waiting for the inevitable to happen and
preparing the case for the icc
well it's it's really difficult and uh i
know that people are terribly concerned
about us and nato getting over committed
in ukraine however i gain i point out
the syrian uh experience
when we eventually attacked assad's key
sites
after the uh nerve agent attack in a
place called khan shakun in april 2017
and then we attacked again in 2018
uh his sights the chemical weapon
stopped asap knew if he used them he was
going to get thumped
we must
ensure that putin understands the
consequences
of his actions and perhaps enable even
more the ukrainian air force and
military to be able to attack some of
his strategic bits of equipment and
strategic sites with more equipment and
i personally think
we should be giving ukrainian army more
more aircraft so that they can um win
the battle in the skies
hey mr brent gordon great to have you on
the show this morning thanks for joining
us